what's going on everybody welcome to
part 13 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this video we're gonna be
talking about a little more
customization then we're gonna get into
open high low close candlestick charts
and some more interesting stuff as well
so first of all what I want us to go
ahead and show is like let's bring up
the chart now it's something you might
want to do from time to time is change
the color of maybe an axes here or
remove the axes entirely or something so
let's go ahead and talk about how either
of these things might be accomplished so
coming on down basically here's where
we're doing all the ax1 stuff right
generally I put the plots in a little
group and then I also put the
modifications in a little group so doing
that would be more like this plot plot
and then the modifications and its own
little group do whatever you want
whatever makes the most sense to you
it's just for me one thing I'm gonna do
I'm gonna go ahead and comment out these
two lines we're not really I see no
reason to change those colors
necessarily but we can if we want the
next thing I want us to go ahead and do
is just basically after the set Y ticks
we'll just come down here and what we
can do is we can do a X 1 dot spines
that's the kind of where those little
tick markers are and that idea the edge
of the graph basically and then you
reference the specific spine that you
might want to change so we'll say spines
and then left right you've got left
bottom top and right so left so spines
left we could dot set underscore color
and we could set this color to cyan okay
another thing that we could do is we
could say a X 1 dot spines and like
let's get rid of the rightmost spine and
the top spine so we would say spines
right dot set underscore visible and
we'll set that to false and then we'll
just take this line copy-paste change
right to top and that's basically it so
let's go ahead and run that real quick
see what we're looking at okay so
it's kind of hard to tell but this line
is indeed cyan okay and then there is no
marker or no spine up here or down here
it's a little hard to tell plus we also
have this silly grey background but you
can take my word for it or like squint
and lean in really close to your screen
to tell so so there's that and it's not
wither let's do a BAE Twitter just
doesn't have that as long a data so eBay
and now coming back up here so we've you
know removed some stuff what about what
if we wanted to make like for example
what if we don't want to lean in to see
that we changed the color of this spine
well what we can do is we can say let me
zoo ax 1 got spines and then we'll
reference left again and we'll say dot
set underscore line width line width to
5 okay so now we are gonna see that that
is a cyan line sure enough we can tell
it's a cyan line nice so then we can
close that a year another thing that we
can do is we can change the little tick
parameters so does like you know down
here so how do we do that how might we
change those tick parameters well we can
come over here let's put these together
and then we'll say a x1 dot tick
underscore params and then we specify
which axes let's do the x-axis axes
equals x and we'll say the colors will
be let's do a these hash colors so these
are called hex colors so generally when
I'm trying to find a hex color codes I'm
really not advertising for this site or
anything I just like this site so I
guess I'm advertising for it but I'm not
paid for it so anyway I always come here
to get my hex color codes but like yeah
let's see we want to do I don't know
this orangish color right here cool
picked it ctrl a copy that bad boy
coming on over here will make the colors
that that color so do whatever you want
but this is f 0 6 2 1 5 okay so we
change that color let's save and run
that and there you go so our little tick
labels here so two thousand six seven
eight all that we changed those colors
now those are you know crazy color
now generally when it comes to like the
spine colors and text colors and stuff
like that you really should not stray
too far from black but black is kind of
annoying but usually what people do with
like text color is you know you start
with a black like this but then you
lighten it just slightly and it just
it's more appealable to the eyes for
whatever reason so that's what most
people do like this is a great example
like this text right here that's not
black that's like a lighter black right
or a light or a very dark gray okay so
in that same with this text and most
text on most websites is not a solid
black so that's why making that little
tiny change maybe these little labels
and stuff that can help but it's not
really required but and pretty soon I'll
show you an easier way than modifying
everything but anyways so those are your
ticks add/remove spines all that really
that's all I actually you know what I
want to show a horizontal lines as well
so let's say let's say cuz like right
now we kind of have this like fake line
being drawn here it's not there's not
really a line that marks that first
price but let's say you really wanted
like a really obvious line there well
what you could do is you can do what's
called an H line and so an example of
doing that would be like this is a plot
so you would put it up with your plots
basically but what you'll do is you'll
say a X 1 diet a X H line so axis
horizontal line you can do a vertical
line too if you wanted and then you
basically specify at what point is that
line well we want that line to be at the
close P zero mark and then we can
specify the color so we can say color
equals and we'll just make it K for now
and then let's also say line width
equals five so it's a real thick line
right there
that marks kind of where we invested so
we can save and run that and there you
go you've got this nice strong line that
marks that point again I recognize this
chart is super ugly the goal is just to
show you the customization not make
pretty chart yet we will get to making
our graphs pretty but for now I just
want to show that options okay so that's
an option for you I don't suggest making
you that fat but that is your option you
can do whatever you want it's your chart
so anyway we're all done at this point I
think with this tutorial if you have any
questions or comments up to this point
or on this tutorial specifically please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time